hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we are in round
2 of our coverage the 2017 grand prix in
geneva the third leg of the grand prix
circuit there's four legs each of these
competitors will be playing in three of
those but our competitors today what's
going to be played by Shecky mama dada
he is leading the entire grand prix so
he played the first two this is his
third leg of the Grand Prix's played in
the first one he tied for first and in
the last one he got 2nd place so if you
look at the leaderboard he is at the top
he's looking for a strong finish to go
ahead and solidify himself as one of the
top 2 finalists move on to the Canada
tournament he's been playing extremely
well he's moved up to worldwide rank of
number 6 he's got his rating at 2800 so
32 years old he's playing the best chest
of his life his opponent arnesto
currently 40 third in the world he's
only played one leg of the grand prix so
far that was the last one and he did
place last so we kind of have two
spectrums here as far as players but
without further ado we will go ahead and
get started
Shakthi it starts out with pawn to d4
Knight f6 a nice f3 pawn d5 upon up here
c4 and then pawn e6 so we got into the
Queen's game of the climb yesterday and
we're going to be treated by another
Queens gambit declined line today as
well then round 1 we solve the knight
coming out to c3 early on we do not see
that from white today instead bishops
going to be coming out here to g5 later
on can solidify with pawn to e3 since
it's outside the pawn chain but this
does open up the door for the bishop to
come down here to b4 kind of with that
nimzo-indian defense that you see a lot
of times that's before the pawn comes up
here to d5 but that's why so many
players will play this Knight up here to
c3 first they don't have to worry about
the bishop coming down here to b4 and
then if a Knight to c3 what they'd like
to play and then you have an exchange
here double pawns on the C file so the
players will just try to avoid those
lines at all possible but here we see
Knight to d2 instead and then the pend
takes on c4 now you may look at and say
well the Queen you just come up here
check
take the bishop but unfortunately it's a
little tricky because just not here to
see six protecting the bishop now you
can see pawn here to e3 light square
bishop attacking the pawn right here but
then Bishop to d7 this you can't take
here on c4 because then just Knight
takes on d4 this is a discovered attack
on the bishop so it's not quite as easy
as it may look to go ahead and capture
that bishop right here with cleen coming
here to a4 so instead without getting
the Queen involved into the game too
early decided to go and just play pawn
here to e3 opening up the door for the
light score to attack this and black has
a couple options here you can try to
hold on to that material or you could
decide to go ahead and just give that
material back and then continue his
development he decides to go and hold on
to it so pawn here to b5 a white
immediately responds back trying to
attack that critical square here that's
protecting c4 with pawn up here to a4
and then pawned c6 this is kind of one
of those if you're going to play pawn to
b5 you pretty much have to anticipate
you're going to be playing this pawn to
c6 next and for what this is where
preparation really comes in really on
the eighth move of the game but there's
a lot of ways to Y can kind of take this
game he could decide to go ahead and
start taking here pawn takes on b5 start
to have an exchange open up this semi
opened file for his rook to gain control
he could decide to go and play Queen to
c2 he could also decide to play pawn g3
fitting fianchetto on the kingside cast
on the Kings side that's an option he
decides to go for Bishop to e2
protecting his knight here on a three
and then allowing himself to castle on
the King side so he can then focus over
here on the Queen side doesn't look like
too much is going to be going on the
King side for a while just because
blacks putting so much pressure on the
Queen side white really has to make sure
that he doesn't get overloaded on that
side of the board now Knight here to d7
can't really come here to c6 like he may
want to but doesn't want to make sure he
gets it involved into the game this more
than likely means the bishop is going to
be coming here to b7 at some point get
that light square Bishop involved into
the game castle on the King side and
then Bishop here to b6 now for a long
time a standard play was
castle on the kingside you see white
castle black castles as well and then
you can see pawn here to b3 you could
see the exchange you could just see
black continue to push pawn down here to
c3 and then that up here to e4 this was
kind of the standard line Black has now
shifted more to the the Queen to b6 kind
of waiting to castle on the King side
recognize he's not under pressure right
now since his opponents not really
focused on the King side attack so just
tries to be more aggressive on the Queen
side white plays Queen to c2 continuing
and completing his development and then
Bishop to b7 this is a spot where black
going to I think it makes sense to go
and castle on the Kings side his lights
where a bishop is going to be blocked
the pawn on c6 hasn't moved he could
eventually move that if you want to have
a discovered attack on the night here on
f3 but does seem like a good opportunity
to go in castle on the King side he
decided to go and play Bishop to b7
getting ready to kind of push forward
with the pawn to c5 as we just discussed
but he will at some point need to have
some King side safety now pawn up to a
b3 and black has kind of a nice little
outpost for his pawn we usually talk
about outpost for minor pieces but this
has some great protection air and
putting a lot of pressure on white
there's just not a lot of great squares
for white to go to having to worry about
this pawn here on a c3 he does bring his
back his knight back here to b1 not the
most aggressive square but no does need
to kind of be aware of how he's going to
maneuver around and kind of pick off
this pawn here on c3 and then pawn to c5
looking to break up the center of the
board and then also preparing for the
bishop to come down here and take on f3
white decides to go ahead and take back
on a c3 since he does have his queen
protection here and then pawn takes on
d4 that up takes on b5 and then the rook
over here to c8 so we see an exchange on
board and then black takes the
opportunity to go ahead and control this
new open file on the C file white plays
Queen to be two attacking the center of
the board here on a d4 and then pawn to
a6 foreseeing
the night to move and then pawn to 85 so
it says okay if you're going to attack
my knight that's fine I'm going to
attack your Queen as well we see the
Queen come down here to c5 and just on
the surface it may look like he's just
basically moving his Queen out of the
way he's being attacked and wants to you
know have it more central in the board
but it's actually doing a lot more than
that the queen is now attacking both the
knife and the bishop right here the
bishop is very key because the knight on
f3 is the lone defender of the bishop
right here and if there is an exchange
on board let's say the bishop comes down
here it takes on f3 then all of a sudden
this bishop is kind of hanging out there
no longer has protection from the knight
so white can't make a mistake and play
something like pawn to h3 this is going
to be bad because then the bishops going
to come down here take on f3
you know a simple response from here if
the bishop were to take then the Queen
could take you could either take the
bishop here you could take the knight
over here so those are all going to be
bad for wipe if instead decides to go
ahead and take with his Bishop here on
f6
okay well the knight could take we could
see the bishop take and then the Queen
is going to take here on b5 a lot of
different options we could see even if
the bishop didn't take here maybe we
swore to see the pawn takes here on d4
okay well Queen over here to g5 this is
just because the pawn came up here to h3
cuz this is forcing checkmate on g2 but
after the bishop takes Queen takes over
here on a b5 black is left with two
minor pieces White's left with one minor
piece so that's what white has to be
aware of after the Queen to c5 it's not
just a simple move I'm getting out of
the way of your attack it's a very
strong attack against his opponent from
here White has a few options he could go
ahead and take with his Bishop on f6
have an exchange he could just play pawn
takes on d4 this does stop the bishop
coming down here to f3 because then the
Queen just kind of ball so that's going
to be bad does stop it from there
could also just play Knight takes on d4
probably a little bit weaker than the
pond taking because it gets tricky for
white as bishop down here c3
this is forking the Queen to the rook
queen kind of has to move
he's going to lose his rook that we do
see in exchange on f6 but could come
back here to c3 maybe he doesn't want to
lose his double bishop pair pawn up here
to b4 kind of an in between moves get
the Queen to move back but then Bishop
comes back here to h4 both sides have a
double bishop pair but at the end of the
day Black has two rooks as well so I
think all in all this would be a better
in game for blacks that's not
necessarily the line that white wants to
go through so he decides to go ahead and
play pawn takes on d4 I think this is
the right route to go with and then
Queen over here to f5 and this is kind
of tricky because the Queen probably
should have come back to e 7 still
protecting the bishop here on a beet
board but it's a little bit safer Square
also protects the night here on f6 does
have protection with his other knife but
what he probably doesn't realize is the
Queen over here to f5 is somewhat in
danger there's a lot of squares that he
can no longer go to he's kind of under
attack here and so white kind of looks
at this and says let's start to form an
attack here brings the bishop back here
to d2 and says hey do you want to go
ahead and exchange bishops black kind of
looks at this not really as a threat
brings his bishop back here to e7 which
is fine but then we see Knight to c3 and
black kind of looks at and says now I'll
take the opportunity to castle
unfortunately he really need to be
playing something else because the real
threat is Knight to h4 because after
black castle down the Kings side nice to
h4 and the queen is lost you can look so
there's a lot of squares the Queen's you
go to yes but all of them end up the
Queen falling it and black just
completely overlooked it afterwards he
just said he didn't realize how much
pressure his queen was after or was
under and he kind of just thought as his
opponent was trying to trade off
material go towards the endgame didn't
realize that it was all leading up to
this position could have easily just
played something like Knight to h5 now
that I can't come to age 4 because
Bishop could take it here on h4 that at
the end of the day would be you know
great for black white would never
do that but instead decided to castle on
the kingside a huge mistake had so many
opportunities to castle on a king side
and so at the end the day white is
victorious after a huge blunder from
black in kind of that middle getting
into the endgame so if there's one
player that's been running well and got
the best of it in this one is Chucky did
and he continues his dominance so he
kind of moves up the leaderboard and is
in prime position to kind of have
another huge strong showing at the third
leg of the Grand Prix here in Geneva so
we'll continue to keep watch on him but
thank you everyone for watching round
two and we will see you again tomorrow
for round three